what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 update video today I have several new
updates and spoilers for you thanks to
the reporters at the Toronto Sun and
there are some pretty big details here
which does confirm several things about
the upcoming season when I'm done
reading this article we want to try and
piece together some of this then we can
get into some speculation so let's get
started according to the Toronto Sun
back in October during filming some of
their reporters spent a few days with
some of the production crew in Northern
Ireland at the Titanic studios in
Belfast which is more or less the main
headquarters for Game of Thrones while
they were touring the sets they met with
some of the cast and crew and they were
also lucky enough to watch a few scenes
being filmed while there they were able
to tour the Citadel which had over 800
bundles of books as props they also saw
Circe's bedchamber which they said was
just as luxurious as you'd expect and
they saw a mysterious earthen dungeon
with a cell and a sturdy door they also
saw the interior of an Ironborn ship but
they weren't sure if it was yours or
Euron's and they also saw that Sam and
Gilly did have their own bedroom in Old
Town it also says they watched a scene
being shot for season 7 episode 2 which
featured a number of different main
characters who were gathered around a
table map on Dragonstone and they were
discussing how they could practice
landing from Circe's grip now that's
pretty interesting because among the
cast were Daenerys Targaryen Tyrion
Lannister missandei glorious and alehna
Tyrell and Yara and Theon Greyjoy the
person directing their scene was Mark
Malad who is signed on to direct
episodes 2 & 3 now this is important and
we will come back to this in a minute
they also said once they were back
outside there was a large tent and this
is where they watched workers sculpt a
massive dragon skull out of foam they
said this skull would be one of 40
skulls that would be used for a
particular scene but they weren't sure
what kind of scene it would be it could
be a flashback a dragon graveyard or
anything else you can think of and last
but not least they toured Winterfell 's
banquet hall where Jon Snow Sansa Stark
Brienne Davos torment and Lyanna Mormont
were filming a scene which they were
discussing the imminent threat of the
White Walkers and Jon Snow said
dragonglass kills White Walkers and
right now it's worth more than
Oh John then told all the northerners
there that they need to start mining for
obsidian so they can make weapons to
fight the way walkers
okay now let's break some of this down
there was a lot of interesting things to
take note of from this report and I'm
going to put the link down in the
description in case you want to go and
read the full report but let's go over
some of this stuff here because in my
opinion these were the most telling
parts of the report first off it says
they were able to visit the Citadel
while on these various sets then they
say they visited a mysterious dungeon
that had a cell with a very sturdy door
one thing that comes to mind when I read
both of these things in the same
paragraph is the dungeon and cell door
that we saw in the trailer and when you
put it all together this must be the
same dungeon that Jorah Mormont will be
kept in while his greyscale was being
treated and I did have a feeling this
would happen I made a video about five
or six months ago where I listed three
ways Jorah Mormont could get his
greyscale cured and one of those ways
was the victory on Greyjoy treatment so
to speak if you look at jours arm in the
trailer it looks to be badly burnt
similar to what victory Owens would have
looked like in jours arm also appears to
be very wet I'm assuming he has been
dunking it in water after it has been
burnt to a crisp Jorah was already given
jon connington s greyscale so they might
as well give him the carry-ons treatment
or mokoros however you want to look at
it so in my opinion when the Toronto Sun
says they visited the Citadel said and
they visited a dungeon with a cell and
sturdy door to me that just screams
Jorah Mormont's new home which we saw in
the new trailer but what do you all
think do you agree with that or do you
think it's another dungeon cell let me
know what you think but let's move on to
the next part of the article and this is
a very important part because it gives
us a better look at the season 7
timeline with this information we know
when some things will and will not take
place
the report says director Mark Malad who
is directing episode 2 & 3 was on the
set of Dragonstone in statuses old war
room with Daenerys Tyrion Gloria Elena
Theon Yara and missandei now we know for
a fact that all of these characters will
not die in the first episode and we also
know for a fact that Yara and the sand
snakes will not be taken prisoner in the
first episode based off this Danny's
entire fleet is going to make it the
dragon stone in the first episode with
getting attacked they must arrive at
Dragonstone on Episode one then by
Episode two they meet in this war room
and this is when they come up with their
strategy to loosen Circe's grasp on
King's Landing this could be the same
scene from the trailer when we see
Tyrion knock over the lion on Casterly
Rock this is most likely when Daenerys
decides to split up her forces in attack
Casterly Rock and possibly Lannisport
before she sends her to throw a key to
take out the other part of the Lannister
army down south in the open field there
was a scene in the trailer that shows
olaria and Yara kissing so they more
than likely leave Dragonstone together
but then this is when they get attacked
by you're on and most likely in this
same episode or episode 3 because when
we see Yara and the sand snakes chained
up by urine and King's Landing the same
director is doing these scenes to mark
Malad who's doing both episodes 2 in 3
Daenerys Mei sent her unsullied to
Casterly Rock and she could send Yara
and the sand snakes with their fleets
the Lannisport but then that's when
you're on must cut them off and attack
them take them prisoner and have them in
Chains in King's Landing by episode 3 at
the latest so I'm kind of glad we got
this report because this did clear some
things up because now we know they all
make it the Dragonstone first before
they get attacked on sea but let's move
on to the next part of the article what
the hell do you think they could be
doing with 40 dragon skulls do you think
we could get another scene in King's
Landing where we saw Arya chasing the
cat back in season 1 or do you think
this could possibly have something to do
with the dragon pit scene that's
supposed to take place in the season 7
finale I'm not quite sure what they're
going to be doing with these so let me
know if you have any good ideas about
this one but let's talk about the other
scene that was being filmed while they
were on set with John songs at Davos
Brienne torment and Lyanna and some of
the other northerners where they were
talking about the dragon glass now I
think this is interesting because now we
know that John definitely makes it clear
that they need dragon glass and they
need to go mine it right away then make
some weapons so when we see the leaked
photos of John on Dragonstone that
doesn't necessarily mean he went there
because the mayor sent him a raven John
could have potentially went to
Dragonstone just to get some obsidian
then when he gets close to the island he
realizes it's very operational with a
new-age Targaryen army crawling all over
the place
how much dragon class do you think
John's really going to be
able to get are they going to get enough
to make weapons for everybody because I
really hope so I would like to see
daggers and Spears and arrowheads and
everything else you can think of that
can be made out of dragonglass
and if Daenerys doesn't believe John
about the threat beyond the wall do you
think she would allow him or his men to
start mining the island how do you
expect this meeting to play out between
these two I kind of hope Daenerys gets
on board with John's plan sooner than
later that way he can get enough men
guarding the wall with at the very least
some dragonglass weapons but comment
below and let me know what you think
about these new spoilers are you excited
about some of these scenes that were
detailed in this article let me know
your thoughts thanks for stopping by and
checking out the video I will see you
all down in the comment section bye